marry here with a GameSpot news update
Shenmue 3 has broken the Kickstarter
record for the highest funded video game
at the time of this recording
Shenmue threes Kickstarter has pulled in
five million seven hundred and sixty six
thousand nine hundred and nine dollars
beating out the five million five
hundred and forty five thousand nine
hundred ninety one of Castlevania
designer Koji Igarashi for blood-stained
ritual of the night it also puts Shenmue
3 at the eighth most funded Kickstarter
projects of all times still well below
the pebble time which is over 20 million
Shenmue 3 was announced at e3 during the
Sony press conference it was revealed
that Sony is involved with funding the
game although the details of the deal
are unknown Suzuki did say that funds
are strictly going to Weis net for
development of Shenmue 3
according to use the zookie Shenmue 3
will offer the full-on Shenmue
experience short teasers have been
released for the game they look great so
there is a freight train of hike for
this game but it's still a few years out
and you can follow all the development
of Shenmue 3 on gamespot.com